[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing curses
more specifically we're going to be
discussing the unforgivable curses
and comparing them to a relatively
unknown curse that is arguably worse
than all of them but together
the curse in question is probably most
similar in nature to the unforgivable
curse known as crucio
the cruciatus curse which also goes by
crucio
literally translates to by torture in
latin
so that should give you a good idea of
what the spell does
crucio is most often used by dark
witches and wizards
and a known proponent of crucio is
bellatrix lestrange
who used it to torture alice and frank
longbottom
when cast crucio inflicts excruciating
pain on the victim
pain so excruciating that it is
considered to be torturous
casting crucio is said to require a wand
and incantation
and its effects are said to vary
depending on the caster's desires and
emotions
to produce the excruciating pain implied
by the name
the caster must despise the victim and
enjoy causing pain
harry potter after crucio was cast on
him described it as feeling like
his head was being split open while
having his bones set on fire
hard to imagine a spell worse than that
it should be mentioned
however that crucio along with the other
two unforgivable curses
were set apart from other dark spells
and that they were very clearly
categorized and outlawed
what's interesting however is that while
these three spells are pretty awful
and their potential for destruction is
high there are other spells that exist
in the wizarding world
that have the same potential for damage
enter transmography and
torture transmography and torture is
first mentioned by gilderoy lockhart
while speculating
as to what spell mrs norris was
inflicted with in the chamber of secrets
it was definitely a curse that killed
her probably the transformography and
torture
i've seen it used many times so unlucky
i wasn't there
i know the very counter curse that would
have saved her there are a few issues
with what gilderoy said
the first being that he couldn't have
been more wrong about his conclusion
from mrs norris's autopsy the second
being that i'm merely 100
certain that lockhart doesn't know a
counter-curse nor does he properly
understand
what transmography and torture is to
begin with
when i first heard of this spell i was
intrigued so i decided to do a little
more digging
beyond all of the nonsense that lockhart
spouts off it turns out that
transmography and torture
is very much a real spell and it's
pretty horrific sounding
transmogrify and torture is like a mix
between the killing curse and crucio
in that it inflicts the victim with
torturous effects
and then eventually kills them how the
victim is tortured is not stated
however if we look at the name of the
curse we should be able to come up with
some theories
transmographian comes from the word
transmogrify
which means to change or alter greatly
often to grotesque effect
bearing this in mind my theory is the
spell contorts the body of the victim
stretching them and pulling them until
they eventually die
there is supposedly a counter curse but
that intel only comes from lockhart
who clearly didn't understand what the
spell was to begin with
i speculated in a previous video that
this may have been the curse that remus
sirius intended to use on pettigrew in
the prison of azkaban
you should have realized if voldemort
didn't kill you we would
goodbye peter at this point the pair
point their ones at him
shall we kill him together yes i think
so
said lupin grimly in closing i'm not
sure how this spell avoided
unforgivable status but then again it
does seem to be relatively
unknown had you heard of this spell
before let me know in the comment
section
below until next time your wizard howry
you